>>> WE ARE BREAKING DOWN NEW
EVIDENCE SHARED WITH THE
JANUARY 6TH SELECT HOUSE
COMMITTEE.
NEVER BEFORE SEEN INTERVIEWS
WITH THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP,
MEMBERs OF HIS FAMILY AND INNER
CIRCLE.
BOTH BEFORE AND AFTER THE
HORRIFIC ATTACK ON THE U.S.
CAPITOL JANUARY 6TH.
BRITISH DOCUMENTTARIAN ALEX
HOLDER WAS JUST INTERVIEWED BY
HOUSE INVESTIGATORS ABOUT HIS
DOCUMENTARY WHICH WILL AIR LATER
THIS SUMMER ON DISCOVERY PLUS
WHICH WE SHOULD NOTE SHARES A
PARENT COMPANY WITH CNN.
AND PROVIDED US WITH CLIPS FROM
THE FILM.
I WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT A NEW
CLIP FOR YOU.
IT'S A PORTION OF THE
DOCUMENTARY THAT FEATURES AN
INTERVIEW WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
DAUGHTER AND ADVISER IVANKA
TRUMP AS THE PRESIDENT WAS
ENGAGED IN A FULL COURT PRESS IN
DECEMBER TO TRY TO OVERTURN THE
LEGAL LEGITIMATE RESULTS OF THE
2020 ELECTION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY THOUGHT BECAUSE PEOPLE
SHOWED UP TO THEIR RALLIES THAT
MEANT THEY WERE POPULAR.
THE IDEA THAT OTHER PEOPLE MIGHT
BE SITTING AT HOME FEELING
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT IT SEEMS NOT
TO HAVE OCCURRED TO THEM.
THEY GENUINELY THOUGHT THAT MUST
BE TRUE.
>> WE WON GEORGIA, MICHIGAN,
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> AS THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID,
EVERY SINGLE VOTE NEEDS TO BE
COUNTED AND NEEDS TO BE HEARD,
AND HE CAMPAIGNED FOR THE
VOICELESS.
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE
IVANKA TRUMP SAY THAT HER FATHER
WANTED EVERY VOTE TO BE COUNTED.
BECAUSE TRUMP'S MISSION IN THE
DAYS AFTER THE ELECTION WAS TO
STOP THE COUNTING OF VOTES.
>> THE REALITY IS PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WERE GETTING MULTIPLE
BALLOTS IN THE MAIL.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
VOTING IN MULTIPLE STATES.
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER THAT THE VOTER FRAUD
THAT THEY'RE CLAIMING.
>> AFTER WEEKS OF TRYING TO
OVERTURN THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION, HIS LEGAL TEAM HAS
COME UP WITH NOTHING.
>> SO FAR THEY'VE LOST 30 CASES.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO RELEASE ALL
THE INFORMATION THAT I HAVE.
I WOULD LOVE TO GIVE IT TO YOU
ALL.
EXCEPT MOST OF YOU WOULDN'T
COVER IT.
>> ALL THE LEGAL DOCUMENTS, IT'S
NOT EVE AN CONTEST, BUT YOU NEED
A JUDGE THAT HAS COURAGE, AND SO
FAR WE HAVEN'T FOUND THAT JUDGE.
>> IN ADDITION TO THAT CLIP, THE
DOCUMENTARY REPORTEDLY INCLUDES
IVANKA TRUMP SAYING HER FATHER
SHOULD COULDN'T TO FIGHT BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE QUESTIONING, QUOTE,
THE SAJTTY OF OUR ELECTIONS.
YOU COMPARE TO WHAT SHE SAID IN
THE DOCUMENTARY BEFORE IT WAS
CLEAR HER DAD WAS NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO STEAL THE ELECTION,
TO WHAT SHE SAID UNDER OATH TO
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
RESULTS.
>> HOW DID THAT AFFECT YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT THE ELECTION?
>> IT AFFECTED MY PERSPECTIVE.
I RESPECT ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR,
SO I ACCEPTED WHAT HE WAS
SAYING.
>> THAT'S A REFERENCE TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR SAYING
THAT THE CLAIMS OF A WIDESPREAD
VOTER FRAUD WERE, QUOTE,
BULLSHIT.
LET'S GO TO PAMELA BROWN WITH
MORE REPORTING ON IVANKA TRUMP.
>> I SPOKE TO A SOURCE FAMILIAR
WITH THE BEHIND THE SCENES
ACTIVITY HAVING TO DO WITH THIS
DOCUMENTARY.
THIS PERSON I SPOKE SO DOWN
PLAYED IT SIGNIFICANTLY SAYING
IT WAS PITCHED TO IVANKA AND
JARED AS A, QUOTE, PUF, PUFF,
PUFF PIECE.
THEY VIEWED IT AS
INCONSEQUENTIAL AND IT WAS
PITCHED TO THEM BY A LONG TIME
LAWYER FOR DONALD TRUMP.
NOW, I PRESSED ON WELL, WHY
WOULD THEY SIT DOWN AND DO THESE
INTERVIEWS DURING SUCH A
SENSITIVE TIME IF IT WAS SEEN AS
INCONSEQUENTIAL.
THE PERSON SAID WELL, IVANKA
TRUMP DIDN'T WANT TO GET INTO A
FIGHT WITH HER DAD, AND SHE WAS
DOING IT AS A FAVOR FOR HER
FRIEND.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT I AM
TOLD ESSENTIALLY WHAT IVANKA
SAID IN THE CLIP THAT
CONTRADICTED TO WHAT SHE SAID
UNDER OATH IS THAT SHE DIDN'T
REALLY BELIEF WHEN SHE SAID IN
THAT DOCUMENTARY.
THAT THIS PERSON I SPOKE TO SAID
SHE DIDN'T WANT TO CONTRADICT
HER DAD.
THAT IS WHY SHE SAID WHAT SHE
SAID, TRYING TO DEFEND HER AND
DOWN PLAY IT.
WE KNOW FROM OUR OWN REPORTING,
JAKE, THAT EVEN IN MID NOVEMBER,
IVANKA TRUMP WAS PRIVATELY
TELLING HER CONFIDANTS THAT SHE
DIDN'T THINK THE LEGAL
CHALLENGES WOULD CHANGE THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION.
AND SO CLEARLY, SHE'S TRYING TO
HAVE IT BOTH WAYS HERE.
PRIVATELY TELLING CONFIDANTS
THAT.
CLEARLY UNDER OATH SAYING SHE
KNEW ONCE BILL BARR SAID THERE
WAS NO WIDESPREAD FRAUD, BUT
SAYING IN THE DOCUMENTARY, IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE A PUFF PIECE,
THAT SHE THOUGHT THAT EVERY VOTE
SHOULD BE COUNTED BECAUSE PEOPLE
WERE QUESTIONING THE ELECTION.
THAT SHE KNEW HER DAD HAD LOST.
>> YEAH.
SHE SAID AS THE PRESIDENT HAS
SAID EVERY SINGLE VOTE NEEDS TO
BE COUNTED.
>> SHE KNEW -- SHE KNEW HER
HAD -- SHE WAS TELLING PEOPLE
THAT PRIVATELY IN NOVEMBER.
>> BUT HER DAD WAS NOT TRYING TO
GET EVERY SINGLE VOTE COUNTED.
>> NO, BECAUSE HE TRIED TO STOP
THE VOTE COUNTING.
>> HER DAD TWEETED THE THURSDAY
AFTER THE ELECTION, STOP THE
COUNT.
>> SO I BROUGHT THIS UP TO
SOMEONE I SPOKE TO TODAY.
I SAID SHE WAS SAYING SHE WANTED
EVERY VOTE COUNTED BUT HE WAS
SAYING STOP THE VOTE COUNT
BECAUSE IT WASN'T GOOD FOR HIM.
THE PERSON, ONE OF THE PEOPLE I
SPOKE WITH TODAY TRIED TO DEFEND
HER SAYING SEE, SHE'S NOT JUST A
MOUTHPIECE FOR HER DAD.
CLEARLY IN THIS CASE, JAKE, SHE
WAS TRYING TO WALK THE L